in this video I want to talk about
transcription transcription is something
that we mentioned before when we talked
about the central dogma now what is
transcription transcription is simply
RNA synthesis the production of RNA
specifically RNA is synthesized from a
DNA template so what is the name of the
enzyme that actually does this it is
called a DNA dependent RNA polymerase or
just RNA polymerase so RNA polymerase
because it's making RNA DNA dependent
because it uses DNA as a template now
what does the enzyme actually do well it
adds the ribonucleotides which are ATP
UTP CTP and GTP to make a strand of RNA
that is complimentary to DNA what is the
direction of the synthesis of the RNA
the direction of the synthesis is 5
prime to 3 prime just like DNA
replication and this is always the case
RNA is synthesized 5 prime to 3 prime
always what about de novo synthesis out
of nothing if you recall I mentioned
that primates lays down a primer de novo
and prime ace is an RNA polymerase so
the answer here is yes an existing 3
prime OAH group is not necessary for RNA
polymerase RNA polymerase can synthesize
de novo so now let's think about this
only one strand of DNA is copied which
one is that well that one's normally
called the template strand that makes
sense right
because we want to use the DNA as a
template to make the RNA it's also known
as the non-coding strand it's also
actually known as the anti sense strand
the other strand is the coding strand
right if this one is the non-coding
strand this one must be the coding
strand because DNA of course is
double-stranded the coding strand is
also called the sense strand it makes
sense okay
so what does that actually mean how does
that work well here's a simple view if
we have a double stranded DNA molecule
one strand running 5 prime to 3 prime
this way the other strand running 5
prime to 3 prime this way if we imagine
this top strand up here to be the
template or the non-coding strand and
this one bought down here being the
coding strand let's see what would
happen if we actually made an mRNA
sequence according to this template
strand the template strand is the strain
that's copied so if RNA polymerase comes
in what it's going to do is it's going
to add rebel nucleotides complementary
to the template strands bases so if this
is 3 prime to 5 prime here then it were
synthesizing 5 prime to 3 prime we're
going to the RNA polymerase is going to
read the DNA strand 3 prime to 5 prime
so that it can synthesize it the RNA 5
prime to 3 prime because it has to be
anti parallel so if if it's just the
small piece here and we want to
transcribe it what we're going to do is
we're going to add a complementary base
so this is an a so the complementary
base for that would be a you actually
let me write that in red so that would
be a U and then complementary the T
would be an a complementary to the to
the G would be a C whoops a C
complementary the C would be a G
complementary to the a would be a you
recall because RNA has used instead of
T's so
notice that what's the difference
between this and the coding strand well
they're pretty much identical right
that's something they should know
they're identical except the RNA or
rather than me explain a little bit
further identical to the coding strand
rather except with use in place of T's
right this is ta see GT here this is UAC
G u so these three are the same a cg
writes the same as the coding strand the
only difference is these T's are used in
the RNA so that's a simplified view of
what's going on here we'll talk about it
in more detail later few more things to
keep in mind or that I want you to
consider how does RNA polymerase know
where to begin transcribing well there
are these things called promoter
sequences now what is the purpose of
promoter sequences well they basically
determine where transcription starts
they determines which transcription
start sites the RNA polymerase is have
hi the RNA polymerase has a high
affinity for these regions that's highly
attracted to these regions and that
makes sense if you think about it right
if the promoter sequences on the DNA are
what determines where transcription is
supposed to start then it would make
sense that the RNA polymerase would want
to be attracted to that punch sequence
and that is actually the case one more
thing I want to mention is that only a
portion of the DNA is copied and this
makes sense if you think about our DNA
containing genes maybe if we have gene
one gene to gene 318 for
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah each gene will
probably encode some sort of protein
product that isn't always the case but
it's usually the case so let's say gee
- encodes for enzyme enzyme - and gene
ten and goes for enzyme ten we want to
make sure that we transcribe only that
gene in order to create later that gene
product that enzyme or that protein so
only a portion of the DNA is copied at
at a time whereas in DNA replication the
entire strand was copied okay so I want
you to keep that in mind I hope that
video was helpful in kind of an overview
of transcription I am a tutor if you
live in Southern California feel free to
contact me via email at move University
at gmail.com see the description below
for more details
thank you for watching